it's spice its moist oh my gosh it
honestly is one of my favorite desserts
out there good god I love carrot cake hi
I'm Ken oh and today I'm gonna be
sharing with you my recipe for the most
moist carrot cake using a box grater the
carrots are gonna be a lot smaller than
if ideas like a store-bought carrot does
it work
hand grading the carrot will make sure
it's evenly distributed throughout the
cake therefore giving it a lovely flavor
throughout and as a leavener I'm using a
combination of baking powder and baking
soda if I added a lot of baking soda I
run the risk of turning my carrots green
it won't hurt you
but it sure is not gonna be pretty now
that all these dry ingredients are
sifted together I'm going to mix
together my wet and yes sugar is a wet
ingredient that always confuses people
confuses me too
with the cake like this molasses and
that brown sugar really kind of like
ways a cake down I'm going to drizzle in
the oil I'm not gonna dump it in all at
once because then I'll have to be mixing
for a long time to make sure it
emulsifies so it's not type of batter
where you're gonna like beat until
fluffy cuz it's just not gonna work
so just only makes things until they're
just combined together so now that the
oil has been slowly added into the wet
ingredients it's time to reintroduce the
dry however I'm not gonna dump it all in
at once what I'm gonna do is I'm going
to add the flour in thirds so I can mix
a bit in and then you know add a little
bit more mix out a little bit more until
it's all incorporated
it looks like peanut butter I'm gonna
add in a tablespoon of flour to the
raisins and this will just help make
sure that they don't sink to the bottom
while baking absolutely as I'm gonna add
in those grated carrots this is my
secret ingredient to making the most
delicious moist carrot cake or crushed
pineapples it is my secret ingredient
adding pineapple to the cake batter will
not only add a different kind of
sweetness in the sugar but it adds in
little acidity some moisture and
pineapples have vesicular enzyme that
helps break down protein the mixed
batter I'm gonna divide into three
8-inch cake pans
this amount of batter could do a sheet
cake so be single there and those are
still really fun especially if you have
to feed a lot of people out of party but
I think a three layer cake is really
pretty and it's really fun to know how
to do just want to smooth out the batter
that's how you can kind of not get that
funny dome shape when it bakes and then
bake it in the oven 350 for about 20
minutes the most important thing to
remember when making icing is that
butter and cream cheese are at room
temperature otherwise mixing is going to
be incredibly difficult now it's really
important to only add in the sugar half
a cup at a time if you did it all at
once it's going to be really really
difficult to work with another benefit
is that you can kind of taste along the
way you can really scale it to your
personal tastes because you can put it
in but you cannot take it out you want
all the tops to be level so what I'm
gonna do is use a serrated knife to make
the tops a bit more flat don't fuss or
stress about losing any of your cake I
mean it's a good snack to have but
she'll know how to take case before you
serve it it's decorating time and I'm
gonna put about a quarter of the icing
on top the best tool to use the spread
is a little offset spatula it's nice and
flat and I'll help get the icing and a
nice even layer so I'm gonna add my
second layer right on top in the middle
Center it shoosh Manish Mir I like a
nice three layer cake because it looks
fancy but it's not that hard to do so
for my final layer I'm actually going to
place it upside down because that is the
flattest part of the cake therefore I'll
have a really nice flat top so I'm just
gonna spread it from the top and then
it's going to come down the sides and
this is where I can fill in any little
gaps I might be in between layers so
everything is nice and smooth there's no
need to stress if you start seeing
crumbs get on the side because what I'm
gonna do is cover the outside with a
bunch of nuts so you won't see it anyway
it's very no fuss before serving it I
suggest popping in the fridge for maybe
thirty minutes just to allow the icing
to set so the cake isn't wobbly when you
cut into it
karacake is such a classic you really
can serve at any occasion it's good for
celebrations it's good if you're just
having a few friends over for a dinner
party definitely just make it your own
and have fun making it oh yes